What do,
why website trace.
I don't want to stop this podcast,
but I gotta pee so bad.
I did two podcasts in a row so you can talk to Jamie for just two minutes.
We can talk about
those.
Is that a pre roll?
Yeah.
Word we read back.
I just have to be so bad.
I ain't mad at you son.
You got a letter right there?
Yes.
No.
You know you la is like this.
Is this the Indycar Sativa?
There is some extra spice in there too.
There's a little extra like I think it's called butter butter.
That why that's like wax.
What?
Yeah,
it's a little bit it.
You can't really tell it to be honest with you.
That's how white boys sets up
the ear.
You'll be okay.
How many people still come up to you about the wire?
I know that obviously Chappelle show,
but the people that come up to me at why they identify by themselves as instant
intellects.
Yeah.
You know what I'm saying?
Like people inhale,
they'll,
it's almost like a cocky,
like I know you want Chappelle on a couple of other things,
but you know what,
I really love you from the wire.
That was a dope experience.
Did you ever watch HBO is the corner I started,
I started,
I think I got a,
I feel like it was six episodes and I watched,
I didn't watch all of it.
I was in that,
okay.
I played a heroin addict and that,
and um,
a lot of people don't know people that are fans.
If you were a fan of the why you definitely been a fan of the,
because so many of the actors came back to after I watched the wire I wanted
more and more content like that.
And so I went back and tried to watch it,
but I just,
I actually enjoyed rewatching the wire more.
I like to show it and I was supposed to,
my character was supposed to um,
build up more.
But uh,
the Baltimore Tourism Board was upset that every time someone goes shooting
bought,
somebody depict it as a,
a drug infested pretty much what it is.
So that's why he went from the,
if you notice the shift in the writing,
it went from the towers to the doc's,
like how to fry it.
We get to the dots.
That's cause they didn't just want to be in the hood like that.
But David Simon,
he was um,
he was like,
Yo,
I like to have,
you know what you did.
So they brought me back for the last,
for the last season.
I've tried to get Joe to watch it,
but it's,
it's like it's 10 years old now.
So it's hard to get back into an old show.
But it's so good.
So many people don't live that way and people are like,
they were like,
definitely why are fanatics,
and when they brought me back to last season,
I was nervous because HBO,
the last season of any show on HBO to writers get vindictive and they do nasty
shit to the characters.
Like to last season of Oz,
it was dudes getting raped.
An Aza wouldn't even on us.
They was like,
dude,
I'm on Nickelodeon.
I'm just trying to get to the bathroom man.
But they was right to me.
I didn't get raped the last season and it was fun.
I know I've got to settle down and choose it for a run.
Yeah.
And it's still,
it's the,
you just got to watch it because it's,
it's so good.
His character comes up at,
at like the best time and he's not to spoiler alert it,
but like the follow the money starts with him.
And like that's a trend that goes,
you know,
that my role would have been like if they didn't switch to tone,
if they would've kept it in the towers.
My Shit was cause I was the connection between the streets and the politics.
I know I could've blown.
I carry it out.
And when I first got busted,
when I was in the room,
I was trying to,
I was going to rob the mansion and we'll tell you Dan,
she said,
what's your name?
I said,
my name is,
um,
uh,
data.
Uh,
my name is day day,
but they mostly call me Damien.
Right.
And then he said,
my name is Daniel.
And they mostly call me lieutenant.
And this have to had already said how old robbed the whole crib.
Cause I thought he was a driver with me and that character's should have been
off by then.
But so it was a good opportunity.
There was another cool platform.
It was dope.
I can honestly say whatever happens in my career.
I was on two shows.
They'll go down and television history,
the wires.
Yeah.